our show is taped on the Warner Brothers
lot everyone in the audience knows that
but at home you may not know this is the
Warner Brothers lot famous lot here in
Burbank California and I heard today
that this lot has unpleasant
connotations for you do you have
unpleasant memories of the WB line why I
think a lot of actors who didn't find
success immediately have a lot of like
horrible stories about studios you know
really just failed out this inside one
particularly awful audition experience
here for this film called Rock of Ages
oh you tried out for Rock of Ages I
tried I tried
why yeah and I have to sing a couple of
songs that I were well beyond my
capabilities and I was first up but it's
like 9:45 morning or something and I had
just woken up brushed my teeth and went
here came here right and I thought I'll
bring a little bottle of whiskey with me
because it really made sense to me at
the time yeah and I thought I'll have I
thought it'll do two things it'll give
me a bit of courage because I didn't
think it was a very good singer and the
other thing it would do would be like
warm my vocal cords so that was a plan
anyway
and I parked right beside the big sort
of water tower thing er yeah famous sort
of WB water tour and I write here we go
time to do it and I opened the door and
I took the whiskey and I drank it and I
as soon as it hit my lips I'd kicked
talking like this like like really not
just threw up I mean I like really threw
up all over side of the car all the
thing all these like executives are
driving by and like no golf buggies and
stuff by the day yeah and then I didn't
think of three I didn't bring like mouth
water
you know mentioning so I went into this
audition smelling of whiskey and puke
sighing really badly yeah anyway that's
what you didn't see me in Rock of Ages
[Laughter]
have a drink no no
you